the II use open borders and freedom of
movement have created many opportunities
for German companies in search of
specialized workers for instance Romania
provided this engineers training that he
earns his money and pays his taxes in
Germany for me was a difficult decision
to come here because I have to I had to
leave my family there in Romania of the
immigrants to Germany in recent years
many came from Poland in 2012 about 17%
nearly 11% came from Romania and 5% from
Bulgaria president of the Berlin School
of Economics and law been tri-set
studies the ever-changing currents of
migration in Europe he says there are
also disadvantages not religious
de-stinkify doubt of course if a country
loses its qualified workers there's a
danger that will hurt its development
but then if it doesn't have any jobs to
offer them it's better they leave for a
while the stephen of ila became the
financial crisis and freedom of movement
in the EU has led to a labor market in a
state of flux in southern europe the
brain drain is noticeable in some places
here in seville for instance cafes and
shops are empty
many young Spaniards and Greeks have
gone to northern European countries the
southern countries urgently need help
from the European Union so they can get
on their feet and preserve employment
opportunities it's very hard to rebuild
once people are gone my accent last
summer
EU members pledged a total of some 45
billion euros to help tackle youth
unemployment in the coming years even
Germany is experiencing a brain drain
with many young doctors leaving in
search of better pay and working
conditions in Switzerland for example
until recently Switzerland was a popular
destination with some 21 thousand
Germans moving there annually around
eleven thousand headed to Austria and
nearly eight thousand to Britain many
observers say southern Europe's brain
drain has only just begun